for the second time in four months an
attempt to remove pedro castillo from
office ends in failure the president
saying the impeachment trial was
baseless
everyone knows that it does not contain
a single element that sustains it we
only find words in the motion that have
no corroboration there's speculation
imaginary connections that don't support
facts and the law
in his brief defense the president
denied involvement in graft allegations
but his opponents say otherwise
the corruption that many defend grant
his accomplices millionaire bids the
prosecution says he has been involved in
influence peddling
analysts say the 20-part impeachment
motion was weak the corruption
allegations are still under
investigation by prosecutors
it has yet to be proven there has been
no evidence we deserve respect
the session was marked by interruptions
and insults and was briefly suspended
outside hundreds of riot police stopped
protesters from getting close castillo's
supporters said he must be allowed to
govern
he was democratically elected and must
be respected it's a legitimate
government those diliquants are trying
to oust him
short eight month long government has
been mired in controversy a poll found
fifty percent of peruvians want him gone
castillo is the fifth president in the
last six years it's no wonder peruvians
are fed up with pedo's political class
castillo has said he has made mistakes
but peruvians are increasingly
frustrated and many say they don't want
to wait for castillo to correct his
mistakes
he's a delinquent castillo has no morals
he has light he doesn't run a good
government he is a shame
the session lasted more than eight hours
but the impeachment had lost steam
before it started opponents were unable
to get castillo's allies to flip their
votes
now castillo says it's time to turn the
page but if not now opponents say they
will find a way to remove him from
office mariana sanchez lima peru